Joe is with us in taxes hi Joe
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for the for answering the call
sure man how can I help so I I look at
my debt ratio and what I'm paying you
know monthly and I'm trying to get into
I've gotten into your channel to the
past couple days I'm trying to budget
better how do i budget the money that I
have left over after you know each
paycheck after my bills are paid
effectively when I don't spend it
consistently I eat out a lot I don't go
to the grocery store consistently I buy
you know dumb stuff here and there how
do I really take that money that I make
and budget that effectively well if I
hired you how old are you I'm 27
what do you do for a living I'm a police
officer okay if I hired you to come in
and said okay here's a family in front
of you and they have this money you
could lay down a game plan in writing
with sixth grade math that shows where
their money should go correct
hmm that's really not the problem the
problem is then actually doing what the
game plan is yeah as a police officer
you run into people who aren't doing
what they know they should be doing all
the time and so you know they they are
texting while they're driving and
they're not supposed to be doing that so
you know everything else right so anyway
all we're gonna do is have a game plan
instead of driving with the rearview
mirror we're gonna look out ahead
forward we're gonna say okay before each
month begins we're gonna give every
dollar of your income an assignment and
the good news is you get to decide that
but then the bad news is you have to
stick to it mm-hmm so what you described
was a certain amount of impulsiveness
and it felt like it felt like you were
not in control
of that in some way the way you
described it and you are in complete
control of that
how did with a flip you know cuz I work
shift work and some paychecks are a
little bit bigger than others well we
just we take our best guess at what this
coming month is gonna be based on the
shift work you've got planned this
coming month what is your income going
to be for the month of September right
and you say okay what am I going to make
on this check and I'm gonna get a check
on this date I'm going to check on that
date I think the check is gonna be about
X and I think that other check is gonna
be about Y and just estimate it as best
you can jump on every dollar and
download the budgeting app and it takes
about 10 minutes then to plan where your
incomes going to go before it goes there
and so for instance if you say I think
I'm spending too much on restaurants I
think I heard you say that then you
would dial that back and you would say
I'm gonna spend this amount on
restaurants and when I have spent that
amount I can't go to a restaurant
anymore mm-hmm and I've done that with
that app it's when I'm budgeting that
out I'm not there's a big you know about
$1,000 a month that I don't know what to
budget with so I don't know you didn't
offend you didn't finish the thing out
there I mean you're supposed to give
every dollar a name and what you should
do with that money is if you've got a
thousand dollars extra what am I gonna
do with that money
you should assign it to wherever you are
on the baby steps baby step one save a
thousand dollars maybe step two is we're
gonna list our debts smallest to largest
and attack them in that order and so if
you find money in your budget because
you got some extra shifts or or just
from good budgeting and sticking to it
you throw it at wherever you are on the
baby steps good question